thank you everyone and welcome to the
Academy's 2019
nickel fellowships in screen writings
Awards okay thank you somebody's excited
nickel fellowships have been awarded by
the Academy since 1986 to identify and
to encourage talented new screenwriters
and to nurture and include diverse
artists and storytellers who are
critical to keeping our industry vital
and relevant in addition to handing out
awards since 2013 this event has
included a live reading of scenes from
each of the award-winning screenplays
performed by a cast of remarkable actors
this is one of my favorite nights at the
academy I've been an eager audience
member for all seven live reads inviting
a whole group of my friends to join me
each year my Posse is out there
somewhere tonight but everyone here is
in for a real treat this event is the
culmination of a year-long process this
year it began with get ready seven
thousand three hundred and two scripts
submitted by writers in 70 countries all
50 states and even a member of the
military stationed outside the country
all seven thousand three hundred and two
scripts were read multiple times by
teams of professional readers and this
year that included three graduates from
the Academy's new diverse reader
training workshop which offers free
training in screenplay analysis to
readers and underrepresented communities
who will hopefully increase our chances
of connecting with unique new
storytellers readers select 1000 scripts
in the first round 365 in the
quarterfinals and 149 in the semi-finals
Academy member volunteers read the last
149 multiple times to select 12
finalists until that point readers have
no information about the writers all the
scripts are red blind it's kind of like
the voice but without those chairs that
swivel around
the committee then reads each of the 12
finalists scripts multiple times to
decide on the nickel fellows for the
year and the five new nickel fellows are
please hold your applause until the end
Aaron Chung for Princess Vietnam Shawn
Malcolm for mother Karen McDermott for
lullabies of La Jolla Walter McKnight
for street rat alley punches her ticket
and Rene Palais for boy with a kite
congratulations to you all
[Applause]
before I before I join you in the
audience I would just like to thank Joan
why senior manager of the nickel
fellowships program and her team Chris
Carr Chi and Melissa park for
beautifully shepherding each stage of
the nickel program thanks also to Randy
Hebert camp managing director of
preservation and foundation programs for
his dedication to the nickel project and
to all the academy gold talent
development and inclusion initiatives
Thank You Randy I'd also like to give a
special shout out to our CEO the
Academy's Don Hudson who's in the
audience tonight we thank her for
enthusiastic support and her focus on
diversity and inclusion in in all
aspects of the Academy and I want to
thank the more than 200 Academy members
who volunteered to read a hundred and
forty-nine scripts in the semi final
round and of course special thanks to
the nickel committee 23 devoted Academy
members and governors who volunteer
their time and worked tirelessly to
assure that this fellowship upholds its
standards and discovers the best and the
brightest each and every year and now it
gives me great pleasure to introduce the
chair of the nickel committee please
welcome acclaimed director and academy
governor Jennifer yuh Nelson